the first live-action Spider-Man movie
was actually a madefor television film
that aired on CBS in 1977 it was based
on the Spider-Man TV series that ran
from 1977 to 1979 starring Nicholas
Hammond as Peter Parker in 1978 we got a
Japanese version of Spider-Man this
Spider-Man was named tuya Yamashiro and
he was a motorcycle racer who gained
spider powers from an alien named Gia in
2002 Spider-Man finally made his big
screen debut in a Blockbuster movie
directed by Sam Ry and starring Toby
Maguire as Peter Parker in 2012 Sony
rebooted the Spider-Man franchise with a
new movie called The Amazing Spider-Man
directed by Mark Webb and starring
Andrew Garfield as Peter Parker in 2016
Spider-Man joined the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Spider-Man was played by Tom
Holland a 19-year-old actor who had
previously appeared in movies like How I
Live Now in 2018 Sony released an
animated movie called Spider-Man into
the spider-verse starring Shmi Moore as
Miles Morales in 2018 Sony released a
video game called Marvel Spider-Man the
game featured Yuri lenthal as Peter
Parker who had been Spider-Man for 8
years